our first headline is what I'm really
excited about because I think it shows a
little bit of progress from the world of
sports which I work in the Indiana
Pacers announced this week that they
have hired the first assistant general
manager that's a woman in NBA history
well why are you laughing
what do you say they hide the first
assistant general manager that's a woman
well there's been lots of is the first
female first and gentlemen general
matter like the word female yeah the
first woman assistant general manager
Kelly crossbow yeah this is exciting for
everyone this is shattered the glass
ceiling and I'll tell you what now that
we have the first female assistant
general manager which no one ever
thought would happen you know in the
patriarchy before it toppled with
Nanette everyone thought there would
never be a safe never be a female the
fourth jab at an assistant by the way
but now that the glass ceiling has been
shattered are we one step closer to a
dog playing in the NBA we didn't mean to
talk about era but two weeks in a row
but the NBA is the most widely accepting
league you know you're not gonna find an
assistant general manager that's a
female in the NFL or in the NHL or in
the WNBA but you are gonna find one in
the NBA and I think that's where you
gonna find your first dog well she did
actually lead the two three WNBA Finals
appearances and W&W and be a champion
you say she do you mean like I mean it
was a girl no Kelly Kraus cop
Kelly crosstalk yeah I'm just saying I'm
still just like trying I'm excited about
I'm fine trying to find the connection
though between like you know Kelly
getting this promotion and in the dog
it's not about the promotion it's the
glass ceiling being gone that was
obviously two dogs out at the end of the
now that Kelly Kelly Kelly Kraft Scott
Kelly Kelly cross cops is through you
know
we're obviously one step closer to a
golden retriever being out there you
know I mean and how much he let me ask
you this once we do get dogs in the NBA
will they make less money than male
players hmm I think so for a while like
that's something that you have to work
up over time you know in the world of
dogs females are more valuable in people
I don't listen I'm a FEMINIST and that I
think that men and women are equal and I
do believe their rules set up to hurt
women in the workplace and I'm glad that
Kelly Kapowski broke the glass ceiling
and became the first female assistant GM
in the world do you think this is sort
of like almost like a wait like a blue
wave but that the women are bringing
these rights that the dogs are are gonna
file don't be like a wave of dogs like
are you see bounds in other sports other
lines of work I think you gotta get the
women in the first to make room for the
dogs you know what I mean like it's not
gonna be a dog friendly locker room
until you get women in there but I'm I
just I just hope they make the same and
if not you know I mean like if a woman
makes 70% of what a man makes I think a
dog should get 65% maybe you know what
how about this air contaminants if a dog
made 70 percent of what a woman makes
would women stop complaining about the
wage gap to me now yeah I think so too I
think that just like feel better but I
think it's a common knowledge yeah you
like at least on a hot dog you know
because dogs know what the hell's going
on they have no clue what I mean let's
be honest like how would you even pay a
dog they they wouldn't know what to do
with that keep the money for yourself
give them some biscuits no but I bet I
bet Kelly cap anamur correct well we'll
know exactly what to do now that she's
broken the glass ceiling and it opened
it up for dogs all right we wrap up this
holiday edition favorite story of the
week maybe a favorite story of the year
headlines from England this week st.
Ives England where a man hired to be
Santa
freaked out a little bit when smoke
machines from a separate event being
held one floor below where he was you
know having kids on his lap caused a
fire alarm to go off in these the man
hired to be Santa immediately ripped off
his hat and yelled at all the kids in
attendance to get the out
hit the out get out of the building
there's smoke yeah it's flying tore off
his hat in his beard with Susy and smoke
his hat and his beard and screamed get
the out as he ran which to me is is
the best way to evacuate kids from a
fire and people were like trying to
defend him afterwards being like he was
trying to do a good thing and it's like
but why why do you throw the f-bomb in
there and why did he ever take up his
face he could have been like hohoho kids
get in the line and follow me outdoors
no it was get the out like clearly
Santa's been through something and yeah
I love this and I think that you know
living in California like we're lucky
enough to do we just we've just had to
deal with the biggest forest fire the
biggest fire in state history you know
that's that's a that's over 200 years at
least the biggest fire we've ever had
and I just wondering like is it that is
it that Smokey the Bear is just not
getting it done is it that people don't
respect smokey you see a picture of
smokey saying only you can prevent
forest fires what if it was just a
picture of Santa Claus tearing up his
own face and the capsule just said get
the out I honestly believe that if
we started doing that if we replace
smokey with the Santa Claus and get the
out tearing up his own face there'd
never be another fire again even if you
like people would freeze to death
because they wouldn't be able to make
fire they'd be so afraid of Santa in his
displeasure you think some was gonna
throw a cigarette in the forest or like
not douse their campfire in water after
after seeing that
got to think of to who that who is the
audience here a lot of it's basically
kids you're trying to you know convince
kids teens about forest fires you know
fire safety to do my kids even know
Smokey the Bear at this point I don't
think he's really making an impact on
the younger generation but you know one
person that they do know is Santa Claus
and Santa Claus for sure
and they they fear him they respect him
and if they heard him yell get the
out they're gonna get the oh yeah
especially if he's tearing his face off
as he says it like I mean that there's
no explanation for that other than you
care about this kids safety so much any
you want to be you want to be on brand
any concern about you know kind of it's
this is an all year campaign like kind
of diminishing the the Santa brand
almost making him a fearsome character
you know throughout the year instead of
something someone special that comes out
just at Christmas Santa gives presents
once a year but the other three in sixty
five days of the year they have 364 days
of the year he can be he can be telling
us about fire safety and fire safety
starts with I mean we all know the drill
you know if you ever catch fire what do
you do Erica get the out screaming
yeah we'll be bad I mean I would you
rather would you rather die in a fire or
watch the Santa Claus Terris face off
and tell you to get the out just
imagine what do you mean but what was
the noise he made before Santa Claus
it's like it's like working with a rich
little you could just you can do
anything
you
[Music]